[Música]
[Aplausos]
cosmovisión
no no estoy hablando de una cadena de
televisión ni de una nueva red social es
un término que se refiere a la
conceptualización que una persona hace
del mundo a través de las experiencias
que viven en un lugar y en una época
determinada
en lo cual interpreta todo lo que lo
rodea y su propia naturaleza
de tal manera que como dice ana y slim
no vemos las cosas tan como somos
las vemos como somos nosotros
me cambio de cosmovisión inició hace 10
años cuando se me asignó una plaza
docente en una comunidad alejada de la
sierra tarahumara la premisa principal
era que yo iba a enseñar a jovencitos
pertenecientes a las etnias para una
igualdad
yo iba cargada de ilusiones pensando que
iba a contribuir a la educación de mi
país
las matemáticas jugarían un papel
relevante ni se diga la lectoescritura
todas las lecciones que yo pretendía
impartir partían desde la razón me
interesaba cultivar el intelecto
la primera comunidad a la cual se me
asignó se encontraba en el municipio de
guadalupe y calvo a 17 horas de mi casa
en un trayecto que parecía interminable
y la constante pregunta que hacía yo a
mis compañeros de viaje que ya conocía
en el camino eran ya vamos a llegar y
ellos un poco enfadados respondían a un
no esperes falta mucho
cuando la carretera se acabó e iniciaron
los caminos de terracería y las brechas
no sólo me adentra en el corazón de la
sierra tarahumara con sus intrincados y
majestuosos paisajes
me emprende a un panorama que rompía con
los esquemas que yo conocía la montaña
amurallada por pinos encinos y estás
catis las estelas de humo que le daban
las casitas inciertas entre aquellos
perros
me pensé a sentir desvalida ante aquella
es decir
porque después de la larga travesía
llegué a una comunidad de menos de 500
habitantes sin agua potable eléctrica
yo estaba aterrada y sin opciones de
retorno
cuando me pueden comunicar con mi
familia fue unos días después que me
llevaron a un cerro para tener señal de
celular
llegué a dicho punto con mi corazón
latiendo estrepitosamente no sé si por
el esfuerzo físico realizado por estar a
más de dos mil metros sobre el nivel del
mar
o por el temor que invadía todo mi
cuerpo o con toda mi preparación
académica estaba en lo alto de una
montaña con personas desconocidas lejos
de todo lo que yo conocía y en un mundo
que era hostil para mí
por fin después de muchos intentos logré
tener dos rayitas de señal en mi celular
balanceando médula oa otros objetos como
antenas receptoras para poder tener tan
anhelada comunicación logré avisarle a
mi mamá que estaba aquí
no era ni el lugar del momento para
describir la situación
ellos lo verían más adelante cuando
fueron a visitar
no me dijeron nada sobre las condiciones
de mi nuevo trabajo y mi vida
supongo que no me dieron ningún juicio
para no influir en mi decisión
y
tal como ulises que partió de ética yo
tenía mi propio dice ulises se enfrentó
a cíclope si nosotros yo debía de
enfrentarme a mí misma ya mis antiguas
creencias en un camino que aún continúa
despedí a mi familia y mientras la
camioneta se iba alejando yo tenía
muchas ganas de llorar
me entró un sentimiento de abandono
pero aún así los despedí
la primera barrera en la que me tuve que
enfrentar no sólo fue el lenguaje sino
la cosmovisión
la interpretación del universo su
universo me abrumaban parecía que había
entrado a una especie de universo
paralelo en donde el tiempo se había
detenido
el inmediatismo de las
telecomunicaciones donde un minuto es
demasiado tiempo
si a eso le agregamos que nací bajo el
signo de aries que según dice al orozco
pues ansioso impaciente bueno yo soy un
arios en toda la extensión aunque no se
vale responsabilizar a los astros
otro punto en mi proceso de adaptación
fue entender el orden natural la semilla
que germina la planta que florece
el fruto que al madurar es benéfico y
nutritivo sin violentar apresurada o
adelantar los periodos cuántas veces no
comprendemos el tiempo de los procesos
aún así como actividad académica tuvimos
un pequeño huerto escolar
un espectáculo ver a aquellos jovencitos
que trabajan en la tierra como si la
acariciaba
cuidándola humedeciendo la desmoronando
los terrones de tierra fertilizando la
incluso renunciando a sus tiempos de
convivencia y recreo
la cuidada con tanta paciencia amor y
cuidado que para mi sorpresa esos frutos
esos cultivos brotaban más rápido
muchas veces olvidamos y queremos
acelerar todo
tenemos que respetar este orden dejar
que la semilla germine y una vez que
termino protegerla de las plagas y de la
maleza
puede decirse que en este cambio de mi
cosmovisión yo siempre tan apresurada
tan ansiosa no comprendía que la
paciencia es una virtud esencial
en la dimensión que me encontraba el
tiempo se había detenido las obras eran
largas las noches interminables no
ocurrían nada relevante no había tráfico
no había aglomeraciones
las personas pasaban largas horas en
silencio ellos pueden pasar sentados y
callados mirando al horizonte largo
tiempo con la mirada tranquila la
respiración serena y los pensamientos o
ciegos
y en esta actividad tan pasiva
hay un entendimiento del ser
yo siempre buscando actividades para no
escuchar mis voces internas bien lo dice
carlos quien mire en su interior
despierta pero está despertar bien debe
sincerarse de comprenderse de escucharse
en una tarea personal íntima e interior
ellos callados me decían a gritos que a
veces es necesario aminorar el pasto
para poder estar atentos a todo lo que
está a nuestro alrededor
observar la naturaleza
es una de sus actividades favoritas en
los que se carece de acción pero impera
la percepción y la recepción cuando
estamos en silencio mental sobre todo
los ruidos se convierten en sonidos que
nos revelan los pasos de una persona el
acecho de un animal o podemos
deleitarnos con la melodía del vaivén de
las ramas movidas por el viento
nuestros sentidos están más dispuestos a
experimentar distintas sensaciones
y en este estado contemplativo existe
una veneración por la tierra que es una
madre que nos abriga que nos dan comida
y que además es benévola y generosa
pues nos abraza por doquier
en esa misma generosidad de la tierra
ellos también son generosos hay un afán
de compartir
con el viajero con el visitante con el
peregrino lo que se posee aún siendo un
simple vaso con agua o una tortilla con
sal
ellos lo hacen del corazón e incluso
tienen una palabra bastante curiosa que
se dice frank ya y entonces es común
escuchar cuando uno va de visitar las
casas para que hable un café a la
maestra disculpen no tenemos azúcar es
que está muy cara
el café se bebe y se aprecia pero más
que el café hay un gesto de
consideración hacia el otro de ofrecer
lo que se tiene sino lo mismo con
consideración
y siempre consciente de que el otro está
dispuesto a recibirlo
julián nuestra cocinera en un comedor
escolar al ver que el equipamiento de
este era bastante precario buscaba entre
las cosas que tenía en su casa alguna
bandeja o un cuchillo que nos pudiese
servir ella que tenía tan poco y que
carecía de tanto no se sentía limitada
para ofrecernos su ayuda
es así que la generosidad no consiste en
lo que se tenga sino en brindar desde el
corazón
en mayo de 2011 aproximadamente llego a
mi comunidad y se me dobla
fue un esguince de tercer grado la
comunidad no tenía doctor
por lo tanto pasaron 48 horas hasta que
yo recibí la atención médica oportuna
obviamente experimenté un dolor físico
muy fuerte
pero más que el dolor físico fue aquella
resistencia que yo tenía a situaciones
que me desbordan en donde la fe juega un
papel crucial
yo no podía moverme y desplazarme y
necesitaba ayuda me sentía muy
vulnerable
la situación que yo experimenté no es
diferente a la que cualquier otro
habitante puede haber experimentado la
diferencia era que yo
no estaba acostumbrada a padecer el
dolor
porque por lo general cuando sentimos
alguna molestia utilizamos algún fármaco
que elevada o inhiben desgraciadamente
esto también lo hacemos cuando tenemos
un dolor emocional y no digo que eso
esté mal sino que debemos de crear
conciencia
mi grado de conciencia precisamente era
muy limitado daba por hecho que la vida
era como una cama donde dormir comida
conectar yate sobre mi mesa por lo tanto
había en mí
afán de juzgar y criticar lo que tenía
sin apreciarlo
después de mi primer año de servicio
aprendí a valorar las cosas por pequeñas
o diminutas que fueran
entonces empecé a disfrutar de huevo
estrellado en la mañana una ducha en la
regadera situaciones que padre decía
eran triviales pero no para todos vivir
disfrutando las pequeñas cosas por
diminutas o insignificante que parezca
es una virtud esencial
bueno aparte de todo esto debo de decir
que
aprendí que mis diez eran un vehículo
increíble los rarámuris se les conoce
como pies ligeros pero más que su
capacidad por desplazarse entre las
veredas los pinos y los montes
ellos te hagan ligeros de equipaje
mental
ellos van de este renacer así como
nosotros vamos en la vida de reto de
oportunidad en oportunidad sin embargo
ellos en su vida lo único que buscan es
llevar lo esencial
si un día van caminando por el bosque
llega la noche buscan comida en las
raíces de las plantas o en las hojas sin
preocuparse porque solo viven el momento
entonces yo me puse a pensar como
transitaba yo por la vida bueno yo
llevaba mucho exceso de equipaje había
en mi interior muchas creencias erróneas
impuestas por el consumismo y la
mercadotecnia
algunas veces logra darme cuenta de ello
otras veces
así como los ciclos se terminan y las
estaciones del año unas dan paso a las
otras pues en agosto del 2017 se me
concedió ubicando la descripción
me enfrenté a un nuevo desafío
el contexto urbano muy distinto al medio
rural en el cual me había desempeñado
nuevos alumnos nuevas situaciones y
entonces entré en un proceso de
revalorización de lo que había
acontecido en los últimos nueve años de
mi vida
y los conocimientos que había
incorporado a mi ser
desde cómo prender fuego con ocote hasta
una forma de vivir más tranquila que yo
sepa no hay un posgrado que empresa
ofrezca un currículum tan amplio la vida
fue muy generosa
porque me permitió una evolución a
través de un cambio de cosmovisión que
surgió de un impacto de un choque
ellos mis alumnos sus familias las
comunidades son una dádiva son un regalo
ellos con sus silencios prolongados me
decían a gritos que a veces es necesario
aminorar el paso a quien dar la mente
escuchar el corazón mirar alrededor para
disfrutar de los pequeños detalles de la
vida
ellos analfabetas de ignorantes con sus
pies cansados y descalzos sus caminos
andados ellos conocían la montaña las
veredas el monte todo aquello que yo
desconocía ellos eran los expertos en su
mundo la ignorante era yo
ellos me enseñaron a mí ellos
trastocaron mi corazón las mejores
lecciones de la nieve y yo
y aprender y enseñar para mí siempre
había sido un proceso totalmente
cognitivo
cuando me convertí en maestra rural
aprendí que las mejores lecciones se
aprenden con todos los sentidos desde el
corazón
involucrándonos los unos con los otros
porque aquellos que están próximos
cercanos tienen un misterio que
revelarnos una lección que enseñarnos y
entonces llegamos a descubrimientos en
cantantes como las leyes de newton
aprender de un cambio de composición nos
lleva a evolucionar y para esto no es
necesario irse a vivir a la sierra
tarahumara
[Música]
se requiere que aprendamos a mirar a
través de los ojos de los demás con
generosidad con compasión
cambiar nuestra cosmovisión nos lleva a
evolucionar como humanidad a vivir mejor
cada día disfrutando de las pequeñas
cosas en paz y con alegría
[Aplausos]